Brandon tu ramassera les ballons avec
Lucas
c'est une petite révolution à Orléans 14
joueurs sont arrivés sur les bords de la
Loire parmi les nouvelles recrues
Grégoire Berthier un milieu offensif qui
a joué en première division au Danemark
à la pointe de l'attaque le club pourra
aussi compter sur le Toulousain Adrien
dabas joueur intelligent selon son
entraîneur il aime faire jouer ses
partenaires tous ont envie de pousser le
club à remonter en Ligue 2
on est tous des compétiteurs et avec
l'effectif qu'on a c'est surtout
retrouver la Ligue 2 c'est notre
objectif principal quand on recrute un
joueur c'est pour voilà pour apporter un
plus dans une équipe donc on sait
pertinemment que au départ c'est pour
cela qu'on arrive autre recrue de poids
Kevin fortuné cette attaquant sera l'un
des grands atouts du club passés par
Lens 3 Auxerre ce joueur très
expérimenté de la Ligue 2 jouer l'an
passé à Châteauroux
a été clair dès le début c'est faire une
bonne saison essayer de remettre l'USO à
la place qu'elle mérite c'est-à-dire en
Ligue 2 à la tête de cette nouvelle
équipe pleine de promesses toujours le
même entraîneur Xavier Colin pour sa
deuxième saison à Orléans il le sait il
doit relever en défi de taille ah non il
y a beaucoup d'attentes derrière
derrière ce club donc oui ça met une
certaine pression mais c'est une bonne
pression finalement c'est celle qui doit
nous permettre aussi voilà de grandir et
puis surtout quand on a l'ambition de
d'aller au niveau voilà il faut
supporter cette pression assumer ce
statut aussi de favori début faciliter
ce vendredi soir avec un déplacement à
Concarneau en Bretagne un des favoris
pour la montée il faudra également
compter sur Nancy ancien pensionnaire de
la Ligue 1 ou encore Le Mans et la
Berrichonne de Châteauroux